let's start with india should we well
that's where we just uh we're picking up
um as far as the prime minister is
concerned as far as the minister is
concerned we need to do a trade deal
with india it doesn't matter whether or
not they are taking oil from russia
well i hope that we can exert some
influence on india which is a strong
ally and good friend of the uk
our trading relationship with india is
going to be an important one not just
now but i think over the course of this
century but i hope that forged in that
friendship can also be
shared values
and a role for india on the
international stage which is about
upholding the rules based system
and
and what the people of ukraine are
fundamentally fighting for which is
freedom democracy human rights
self-determination so um you know i hope
the prime minister's visit to india is a
success is labour not concerned that
india's actions are undermining
sanctions
i think that's the the concern
right across the piece when you look at
the countries that have imposed
sanctions those that haven't there's
still an awful lot more that the
international community can do right
across the board to
increase pressure on russia there's
evidence the sanctions are working
president putin himself has acknowledged
on russian state television that there
are consequences as a result of western
sanctions
but i i would urge countries around the
world to really think about how they
would feel if this had happened to them
if their
borders had been violated in this way if
their freedom to determine their own
foreign policy was under threat in this
way
and more devastatingly if lives were
being lost and bodies were being piled
on the streets in the way that we've
seen in ukraine in the wake of the
russian invasion education secretary sat
there as i said an hour ago exactly
where you are and he said uh that your
leader has misled parliament over uh the
bbc and he needs to look at himself in
the mirror this is just a joke right
boris johnson on his way to india
acknowledged that his own spokesperson
had misled journalists however
inadvertently about what had happened at
a meeting of conservative mps so instead
of writing letters to
maybe the conservative party will write
letters to the prime minister's
spokesperson and clear that up what i
thought was extraordinary was that while
the conservative party have
said that what boris johnson was alleged
to have said about the bbc wasn't true
they haven't denied smearing the
archbishop of canterbury we've had
conservative mps out on easter sunday
trying to tell the archbishop of
canterbury what he could and couldn't
say in his easter message and now trying
to smear the archbishop of canterbury
suggesting the church of england had
somehow been
more soft on russia than the archbishop
of canterbury has been on on the
government's
approach to rwanda and as an anglican i
find that deeply offensive but i also
would just say especially to decent
conservative mps who must be horrified
at the way boris johnson behaves how
many more institutions in this country
are you going to allow the prime
minister to trash smear the archbishop
of canterbury lie to parliament if not
in this case
if not in this
case allegedly in there because
otherwise you're not in trouble because
he allegedly i think we don't know that
he did it as plain as the nose on my
face that boris johnson has lied to
parliament we need this parliamentary
investigation because the rules of of
the palace of westminster assume that
the mps and ministers act with honor and
integrity and don't lie we're not
allowed to call each other liars we need
an investigation to to
to demonstrate that boris johnson has
lied but look the voters aren't daft
look at the what they're saying majority
of people believe boris johnson lied a
majority of people believed that he
wasn't sincere when he apologized a
majority of people believe that boris
johnson should resign and they're right
because i can't imagine any one of boris
johnson's conservative predecessors in
my lifetime margaret thatcher john major
david cameron theresa may
lying in such a bare-faced way in the
way that boris johnson has done over the
over the conduct in number 10. okay so
as far as the privileges committee is
concerned why don't we just follow due
processes what the conservatives are
saying we can get to that but there are
two other investigations going on at the
moment hold your horses let those finish
and then we'll move on with that one and
labour's motion which is a cross-party
motion today supported by a whole range
of opposition parties acknowledges that
the privileges committee would be
required to take into account the
metropolitan police full investigation
and sue gray that doesn't mean they
can't or shouldn't start work straight
away and what we've got today
well because okay the way that
parliament works uh we can't actually um
challenge boris johnson on his conduct
except on a motion like the one we have
today and a process that we're trying to
instigate today and we're not allowed to
call boris johnson a liar in the house
of commons even though that's what many
of us believe that he is
and this is about a fundamental
principle in our democracy about basic
truth integrity and decency and
standards in public time scale for that
you can do that once the other two
investigations have finished well i
think we've got to we got to get our we
got to get our work to go on and get our
act together because lots of people the
conservatives are saying uh we need to
move on to other issues we need to draw
a line under this well let's let's get
on with the job parliament's got to hold
boris johnson to basic standards and
decency
and
you know i think what boris johnson has
done
is just so unlike anything we've seen
from british prime minister in certainly
modern times but i think throughout
our history of that office
and that's why parliament has a duty to
hold into account because if we let this
slide if we let this precedent
go
then
what's to prevent future prime ministers
from doing the same or doing anything
saying just wait until the other process
is finished and then bring it in due
process but i i think k that's what our
motion today allows for what the
conservative amendment today is about is
trying to
provide cover for boris johnson to try
and distract and deflect and and to
allow their mps to go back to their
constituents and wash their hands of
this when actually what's happening is
as well as trashing a whole load of
institutions in our public life
boris johnson is also trashing one of
the oldest and most successful political
parties in in the history of western
democracy the conservative party and i
know many decent conservative mps
are agonizing about this and i fear that
many of them despite their misgivings
about boris johnson despite knowing he's
not up to the job despite knowing he's
lied to them and lied to parliament lied
to the country and even lied to the
queen they will troop through the
lobbies like lemmings today because they
don't have the courage to stand up for
what is right they don't have the
courage to stand with their voters it's
a waste of time voting then well i think
it will i think conservative mps need to
show where they stand today and if they
don't stand with their voters on may the
5th the voters have a chance to send a
direct message to boris johnson and to
conservative mps because
i i don't believe that the conservative
party
is a fit and proper party any longer i
don't believe that conservative mps are
upholding basic standards in public life
i don't believe that they're standing up
for their constituents i don't believe
they're standing up in the national
interest i'd love them to prove me wrong
today but if they don't i would appeal
directly to decent conservative voters
in many cases lifelong conservative
voters who are horrified by what they've
seen from their prime minister i urge
them to use the may the fifth elections
to send a direct message to the
conservative party to boris johnson in
the hope that we get better leadership a
better prime minister and a better
conservative party which is in the
interests of of of basic democracy and
decency why do you stand on civil
servants going back to the office
well look i'm i'm probably more
convinced of the benefits of flexible
working now than i was pre pandemic
speaking personally as an employer let
alone anything else
i do think that there are real benefits
to being in the office to working around
in teams there are also benefits to
flexible working and i think we need a
common sense level-headed approach to
this um and and i hope that um i hope
that's the approach that permanent
secretaries and and their managers so
not back to the office five days a week
but some sort of hybrid yeah i think it
will be different for different people i
mean i suspect in some parts of
government i have to come to the office
together well yeah well i suspect in
some parts of government people have
never left the office and and i suspect
to be fair to lots of civil servants i
suspect when they were in the office
they weren't having a party during
lockdown um but you know you're always
on point i think well i i think to be
honest kate i i understand the
frustration voters feel when we keep on
coming back to this issue sometimes are
just genuinely outraged and i don't
think people should
underestimate
why we're outraged which is partly the
issues i've talked about in terms of
decency but also spent time with covid
brief families who are who are
absolutely furious with rage at the pain
and sacrifices they went through at the
way in which they took so seriously the
rules that boris johnson took so lightly
okay mr streeting we must leave it uh i
know you've got a very busy day ahead so
i'll let you go thank you thank you very
much indeed for joining us much
appreciated thank